okay sona's laughing really hard and for
good reason
ladies and gentlemen soda don't cover up
your mouth your laughter is the fuel for
this podcast
I was just recently on the east coast
and Sona
I got gerbils you got gerbild I got
gerbils
okay this is true God this is the
hardest I've seen Sonic laugh in a while
I totally got gerbilt for anyone who
doesn't know what I'm talking about I
put it out there recently as as many of
you know the uh the way to the way for
any fan of the podcast or regular
listener to let me know when they see me
strolling around and man I'm hard to
miss is to shout out
as God made her since katakai just works
but so many people shout out katakai as
God made her and um I think you guys
have been with me but when any ask
anyone who walks around with me Adam
you've seen this happen when I walk
around so many people shout out katakai
it's happened to me it's happened to you
it's happened to me wow
everywhere I go I hear a katakai and I
always turn and go yes I saw it in San
Francisco you saw it in San Francisco
that's right Eduardo uh you and I were
walking around San Francisco as we often
do together we have our little weekends
that's our business not anyone else
that's nice
um we feel accepted there yeah and uh
anyway
uh recently I was talking to someone on
the on the podcast and and I brought up
you guys were here for this that one of
the uh early guests on The Late Night
show was Mick actor Mickey Rooney who in
1940 was the biggest star in the world
and Mickey Rooney came on the show and I
was talking to him and at one point he
was he got off track on something and he
he was trying to talk about mention uh
he wanted to come up with the name
Richard Gere and he was saying that
actor you know the actor what was his
what was that actor's name and of course
there's that famous rumor about Richard
Gere so I'm trying to think like well
what act are we talking about here and
we're and Andy and I at the time that's
like 1993. this might be the fall of
1993. we're both children doing this
late night show
trying really hard to help him come up
with the name like well who is it who is
it and Mickey Rooney said all of a
sudden says and he says it very
ominously like he's telling a ghost
story there was talk of gerbils
and immediately Andy starts howling I
start howling and we say Richard Gere
and he's like that's right what's your
gear and so
um we then decided we start laughing and
then we decided there was talk of
gerbils should be the new category
katakai has been retired has been
retired and the new one is there's talk
of gerbils now we were that episode I
think had just gone out and where am I
I'm in New York City and of course it's
very crowded it's you know uh spring has
sprung everyone's out and around the
weather's perfect I'm in Midtown because
I go to sirius to record the podcast
there and I'm walking along and I just
hear there was talk of gerbils
and I I was like yes and then I turned
around and I walked over and I hugged
the guy oh I gave the guy a hug which by
the way he seemed happy with the hug had
I sensed any reluctance I would have let
go after 15 minutes someone who's gonna
yell there was talk of gerbils out loud
in public is going to be fine with a hug
hey whether you're stuck in traffic or
streaming your favorite podcasts that's
where I come in it's important to have a
network you can trust wherever you are
say it with me T-Mobile yeah you didn't
really have to say it with me but it is
your network you know I'm excited about
T-Mobile yeah you're killing it and uh
you know who's really excited it's our
good friend blay who's been using this
service blade tell us about it yeah I
have been a T-Mobile a subscriber for a
really long time it they're awesome I
download videos all the time yeah you do
you like you download a lot of videos
yeah now you've never read a book
books are overrated but uh and I listen
to this podcast on a hike fantastic up
in the mountains you listen to our
podcast I will contract you work here
yeah I have to I have to I have to
listen to it but it's great and and
honestly like the coverage is is insane
uh and yeah I love the service I love
the phone it's fantastic experience for
yourself how T-Mobile is America's
largest and fastest 5G Network you can't
top them I like all the G's you bet you
do find out more at t-mobile.com Cy
that's
s-e-e-w-h-y fastest based on median
overall combined 5G speeds according to
analysis by UCLA of speed test
intelligence data 4.
Q4 2022 good wow that's incredible yeah
I said exactly what they wanted
5G details at
t-mobile.com anyway I told him he was
the first wow
um did it take you a second to process
it or did you immediately know what that
was for I immediately I immediately knew
I immediately knew and I turned around
and and there he was and uh uh very nice
uh young fellow
maybe maybe 20s 30s but I just I just
immediately was like I had to tell you
you are the first and then it happened
one or two other times while it was in
New York City and I thought it's
spreading there was talk of gerbils
you're reigniting that rumor I bet
Richard you're really happy I know well
maybe the brass ring will be to get
Richard Gere to yell at you in public
you know there's only one person angrier
than Richard Gere right now and that's
the gerbil okay he's still living gerbil
finally oh yeah no these dribbles live a
long time I would have thought that the
whole thing itself would have killed him
no no no oh no no no they don't
suffocate no no lots of nutrients up
there anyway
and so uh no somewhere there's a gerbil
with a uh I think we know where it is no
no he's gone he's long gone okay he
burrowed out yeah
he's constantly texting Richard Gere and
Richard Gere isn't returning his test oh
he's ghosting yeah he's ghosting the
gerbil and the gerbil's like what the
it's a broken heart situation as
well well the turbo also was kind of
happy that I put this behind me there
was a time where he tried to I think he
was on like a VH1 reality show for a
little bit oh yeah and he was hanging
around with you know uh you know some
like a child star and um Corey Feldman
yeah exactly and but he's now he finally
put it behind him and then now this is
reignited he put it behind him huh all
right come on you're better than that
that's the that's the bar come on you
just hit the bar grow up Sona H mosesian
how dare you you keep inserting false
middle initiatives into peoples
so if someone comes up to us and says
ketakai do we go like we're not allowed
to catch up dick yeah
hey prick you didn't get the memo 2020
too much eat
no I don't know katakai is still
accepted okay it's still oh it is I
thought it was retired no it's not
retired but come on redeemable for the
same amount of Praise I'll say this I've
been in this business long enough to
know that any recognition or acceptance
is a golden coin I am not about to give
people a hard time for saying the wrong
thing to minute when I'm walking by but
yeah he was the he was the first one
that's cool and I rewarded him yeah
gerbils was the hug the reward
oh I had another I I had another moment
in New York City
um so many things happen because you're
just out there and you're and there's a
lot of fans of the podcast out there
which is really nice and
um I actually mentioned this story at
the SiriusXM up front in front of a big
audience of advertisers and they found
it quite amusing but I'm walking with my
friend Eric you know Eric well yes they
do and uh Eric and I have these long
walks from we're both interested in uh
you know politics and history and Eric
just shouts at me most the time yeah his
uh and and I it's louder than I am he is
louder than you which is really saying
something but we have a great time and
when we go to restaurants together
um he's always saying what you don't
understand about Lyndon Johnson oh my
God is when he named Fortis to the
Supreme Court he didn't know and people
are always looking over it but I love it
I love him and we always have a blast
together what didn't he know about
abeford hold on yeah I'm kind of I'm
kind of on pins and needles myself we'll
get to you I'll give you your Abe Fortis
man it's about time made before this
came up on this podcast big shout out to
everyone at the Lyndon Johnson Library
came up in the segment about gerbils
yeah exactly I segued what other what
broadcaster in the history of the medium
Segways from Richard Gere's gerbil to
Abe Fortis
the
Supreme Court
nominee by Lyndon Johnson to the Supreme
Court anywho
I really got Sona today but anyway this
is good guys so I'm I'm walking along
and we're headed to this restaurant
that's actually in uh at the Museum of
Modern Art that Eric knows about he says
oh we should go to this restaurant so
we're walking in and uh this very like
accomplished looking young woman uh who
seems very cool last name is just she
says oh hi Conan um you know fan of the
podcast and we're chatting just a little
bit before we just before going to the
restaurant
and uh
and she's great she's fantastic she
seems very cool and cool I mean she
seems very cool and cool yeah that's
great let me fix that part
I'm very flustered
um I saw a girl
and now I'm leaving this in now you have
to leave it in
I saw a girl and got excited
anyway wonderful young woman chat and
then uh I'm about to head back into the
restaurant and I say hey would you like
a selfie I offer it up I just say hey
would you like a selfie and she says no
I'm good and but she said it just like
you know no I'm not that kind of fan
like but she just says no I'm good and I
and I say but a lot of people like to
get itself and no one here's what she
said she said oh my God you're you're
needy just the way you are on the
podcast like and I said she had this
kind of moment of you really are that
guy yeah and I said yes I am that guy
but I thought that was a funny moment
she thought you were this is
experiencing in 3D yeah like she's heard
uh you know uh sonically the neediness
but then she ran into uh she saw it in
person yes yeah so
you didn't take a picture with her no oh
and then the crazy thing is I thought
eventually she'd be like um okay you
never know yeah no she she didn't we got
a courtroom artist to do a sketch of
both of us yeah but uh anyway uh we may
hear from her too because I think
because this is crazy I'm not even
kidding I ran into her a second time in
New York when you were just following
her trying to get her to take a picture
yeah
you sure you don't want a selfie you
us healthy
Sophie with me
I was in a dirigible flying over New
York looking for her no I accidentally
ran into her again and I gave her David
hopping's info and David hopping uh may
hear from her in which case maybe we'll
link up with her on the podcast because
she can she can tell the story herself
but anyway she probably won't get in
touch with him no no she wants out she
lost that number
I called David every four minutes
have you heard from the lady yet they
didn't want the selfie